violence is part and parcel of finchy
life I learned how to stitch up a
bleeding wound load and fire a shotgun
my hands did these things but I was
never easy in my mind
[Music]
I held his heartbeat in my head all the
time he was gone I only pray for him but
when I was a liberator people lined up
in the streets waiting for us sometimes
I actually miss it yeah me too
you want to always talk about how order
not only pause the only way to get out
from under their forehead don't want you
welcome for her I won't be working for
them I'd be working for us
I know if the fight for my country to
come back and find ahead and changed a
bit
I don't know what they let you do over
there but you weren't Mississippi now
you use the back door
Jamie saw in a different way and when
his eyes were on me I felt like I was no
longer invisible
I seen you sniffing after him maybe
Henry is too thick to notice but you
better open your eyes big brother you're
so busy worrying about yourself they
farm you can't even see your own wife
it's miserable
they work this land all day like I used
to walking away for the fight I know
never would beat is you don't need to go
to me I can't stay here they work
entities sweated this way didn't he
bleed they bleed daddy dad
[Music]
that would never be this but I think of
the farm I think of mud I dreamed and
brown way down
[Music]